I'm an idiot I don't understand very
complicated things so I ask a lot of
questions just so that I understand it a
long time ago I had a client they
invited me to sit in on a meeting from
the consultant that they had hired well
the CE level executive is sitting there
nodding I didn't understand a freaking
word of it so I'd raise my hand and say
I know I'm the only person in this room
without an MBA but this doesn't make
sense can you just say it again please
I'm really sorry to slow the meeting
down everybody and one by one all the
sea level Executives said yeah I don't
understand it either now if the idiot
hadn't spoken up and said I'd understand
they all would have nodded their heads
for fear of looking stupid and they
would never have used it would have sat
on a Shelf
and it's because I'm okay being the
idiot but the reality is once I can get
to the point where I understand it I can
say it in simple terms that means other
people understand it too there's a lot
of value being the idea